mais là c'est la rémission de l'élu dans
le derrière donc c'est votre film qui
sort en cassette et qui sort aussi en
dvd pour les riches je le dis voilà donc
ça sort en dvd
donc vous avez toujours refusé que vos
spectacles sortant cassette vidéo wii
sont pas filmés sont jamais ce spectacle
génial que quand vous disiez j'ai des
cousins qu'on débite énorme ça c'est
parce que j'aime ça jamais tomber canon
et les j'en ai fait un autre que j'ai
joué six mois au théâtre de paris
mais non plus non plus long cela je le
verrai jeunes mais pour le coup voilà
vous allez reprendre je bats j'ai une
grande nouvelle à vous annoncer que je
serai sur la scène des folies bergère à
partir du 26 septembre génial c'est une
très très bonne nouvelle
je me demande de vous arrêter je me
demande donc je vous demande de vous
arrêter
bien alors donc le dernier deux voisins
était et toi aussi arrête toi enfin
quand même qu'est ce qui la gêne est là
qu il est même pas maire de paille
edwards et nous sommes bien alors un
film de vous avec vous claude rich et
dieudonné
oui le derrière alors je sais je vous
raconte l'histoire vous le faites n'ont
aidé à l'isie sait plus s'il veut faire
alors c'est à la mort de sa mère une
jeune femme se met à rechercher son père
elle part à paris et elle découvre qu'il
est homosexuel et pour se faire admettre
elle se fait passer pour un garçon alors
au départ le film devait s'appeler maman
j'ai sucé papa c'était une boutade
un amer d obliger de main morte démenti
à chaque fois ci à la télé à la non
c'est une blague
c'est une blague donc ce qu'il faut dire
c'est que le jeune fille en question
s'habillant garçons voilà en garde si ça
vous plaît cette chanson oui j'aime
sylvie ou chantier ça comme tu es tu au
canot dingue non
voilà je sentais les chansons de bourvil
surtout à assurer oui je vais pas vous
donner une chance au fait ces dix là il
va me demander
je connais armissan il va me demander
une chanson de blanc et les mecs et vous
auriez pu j'aurais pu thierry baril le
couple claude rich de donner des flops
fantastique oui oui j'ai quand je les ai
vus ensemble j'étais sûr que c'était
très bien